بعض الناس كانوا ما يعني يرفضوا يخرجوا من
غرفتهم يعني ما بده يشتغل ولا يبدو كذا
قاعد غرفه سجن حاله ببيته ما عاد عنده
قدره على التواصل للانساني انتحروا او الى
ما هنالك
فانت تحتاج الى زمن قد يطول او يقصر حسب
البنيه النفسيه لكل شخص يعني مختلفه من
شخص الى اخر حتى تستطيع ان تخرج من
القوقعه
خروج نهائي طبعا ما في خروج نهائي هذا كان
سؤالي لك هل خرج من القوقعه خروج نهائي
خلاص تخرجا جزئيا
قد يزداد مع
مرور الايام
وتعقبه
وابتعاد ابتعاد
يعني الذكرى تبع ايام السجن وهل سنرى او
نقرا
قوقعه ثانيه ان شاء الله هل بدات بكتابتها
الحقيقه في هناك محاوله بس لحد الان يعني
ما انا حاسمه وفي بعض الامور
ما الذي يجعلك تتردد بعد كل النجاح الذي
لقيته للاسف ولو على واقع ماساوي عشقه
شخصيا ولكن بعد كل النجاح المبهر الذي
حققته القوقعه وكذلك رقصه القبور
يعني هلا انا كان في دافع
بكتابه القوقعه كان في دافع عام ودافع خاص
الدافع العام او والدافع الخاص في البدايه
انه كان هناك شيء ثقيل ما داخل صدري
مثل عمليه البوح بين صديقين يعني هناك همه
تبوح فيه لصديقك تخفف عن نفسك يعني فكان
هذا دافع موجود وكان في دافع تاني هو ان
انقل للاخرين للناس
ماذا يجري داخل جدران السجون
فهذا كان يستغرب انه ممكن تكون الحياه
ماشيه عادي مره والناس
فهدافعين هدول هن اللي خلوني يعني اكتب
الروايه يعني هدول هلا خليني اقول بصراحه
يعني مع الموجودين من الدافعين الدافع
الدوافع
وبعدين يعني
الجو العام اللي موت عم تعيشوا سوريا يعني
ومستقبل سوريا الغامض
لحد الان ما حدا يعني اكبر المحلين
السياسيين يعني سواء كان سوري او غير سوري
ما نقادر على التنبؤ بما سيحدث لسوريه
بلدا وشعبا وقيانا ولاجئين وارضى كل هذا
يعني يدخلك في جو من الاحباط الشديد في
لشخص مثلا او لناس
قبضوا حياتهم في سيبيها هذا البلد والذي
يجعلك ربما تحجم عن الكتابه شيئا اذا
الدافع يعني
لحد الان ليس قويا يعني